hey everybody i'm off the grid for
august but my team wanted to highlight
this clip from black lesbian press
secretary karine jean-pierre but but let
me ask you it's called the inflation
reduction act
but the congressional budget act
office which is nonpartisan said that
there would be a negligible impact on
inflation this year and barely impact
inflation at all
uh next year i mean isn't it almost
orwellian how can you call it inflation
reduction when the nonpartisan experts
say it's not gonna so i appreciate that
i appreciate the question we've actually
addressed this the cbo it was the top
line number there's more in there that
shows uh that it will have the money uh
from remember how we're doing this too
it's it's making sure that billionaires
in corporate america are pairing up
paying their fair share making sure that
it's that the tax code is a little bit
more fair and so when you do that when
you put it in its totality you will she
see that it will it will bring down
lower the deficit
which will help fight inflation